hello everyone welcome to part two of
our series on nlu and ir
this screencast will be a crash course
in classical ir as well as evaluation
methods in information retrieval
let us first define the simplest form of
our task namely ranked retrieval
we will be given a large collection of
text documents
this could be all of the all of the
passages in wikipedia
perhaps a crawl of parts of the web or
maybe all of the documentation of
hugging face or other software libraries
this corpus will be provided to us
offline that is before we interact with
any users
and we will be able to spend a one-time
effort at organizing or otherwise
understanding the content of these
documents in the corpus before we start
searching
online though
we will receive a query from the users
which could be a natural language
question written in english for example
the goal of our ranked retrieval system
will be to output a top k list of
documents sorted in decreasing order of
relevance to the information need
that the user expressed in the query
so this might be the top 10 or the top
100 results
so how do we conduct this task of ranked
retrieval
as it turns out we've already looked at
a way for doing this before when
discussing matrix designs
in particular we know that we can build
term document occurrence matrices
and in such a matrix like the one shown
each term document pair
has a corresponding cell in which the
matrix will store the number of times
that the term appears in the document in
our corpus
of course we will probably want to apply
some sort of re-weighting here because
we don't want to work with these row
counts but once we've done that we can
already answer queries that contain just
a single term pretty well and to do that
we would basically just return the k
documents with the largest weight after
normalization or other processes for
this single term
and again as it turns out this is
precisely what is done in classical ir
if we have just a single query just a
single term in our query
when we have multiple terms in the same
query
classical rir tends to treat them
independently
so we would basically add the weights up
across all of the terms in the query
per document and then that's the score
for the document this is precisely the
computation that's shown here where we
compute the relevance score
between a query and a document
we would go over all the terms in the
query and simply add the corresponding
document term weights for all of these
terms
for that document
this gives us a score for the document
and we can then return the k documents
with the largest total scores
interestingly this reduces much of
classical ir though of course not all of
it to thinking about how do we best
weigh each term document pair
which has an undeniable similarity to
our first task this quarter in homework
one
except of course here in ir we look at
term to document relevance and not word
to word relatedness
so thinking about term document
weighting
here are some intuitions that might be
useful as we think about what makes a
strong term waiting model in ir
of course later in the next screencast
in particular we'll be looking at neural
models
that go beyond this
but for now perhaps the two most
prominent
intuitions for term document waiting are
connected to our first unit's discussion
of frequency and
normalization in particular
if a term t occurs frequently in
document d
the document is more likely to be
relevant for queries that include the
term t or so is one of our intuitions
and um you know in terms of
normalization if that term t is quite
rare
so if it occurs in only a few documents
overall we take that as a as a stronger
signal that document d is even more
likely to be relevant for queries
including t
lastly if document d is rather short we
take that as also yet another signal
that might increase our confidence that
the term t was included in that rather
short document for a reason
taking a step back and thinking more
broadly we're still functioning under
the same statement from the first unit
our goal is ultimately to amplify the
important signals the trustworthy and
the unusual and to de-emphasize the
mundane and the quirky
there are so many different term
weighing functions in ir
but most of them are directly inspired
by tf-idf and take a sim a very similar
computational form
for tf idf this is a slightly different
version to the one used in unit one what
i have here is slightly different
this is the more popular version in the
context of ir applications but ef idf is
overloaded frequently and you will see
multiple
implementations
if you go look for them
so we'll define n to be the size of the
collection
and df or document frequency of a term
the f of term
to be the number of documents that
contain that term in the collection
then tf or term frequency of a term
document pair
will be defined as the logarithm of the
frequency of this term in this document
with one
just for for mathematical reasons
idf or inverse document frequency is
defined as the logarithm
of n divided by the document frequency
of the term
tf-idf is then nothing but the product
of these two values for each query term
summed up
at the end to assign a single overall
score to each document by summing up
across all query terms as we've
discussed before
of course higher scores are better and
the top case scoring documents are those
that we would return to the searcher if
we were to use df-idf
notice how
both tf and idf grow sublinearly and in
particular logarithmically with
frequency
and one over df respectively
a much stronger term weighting model in
practice is bm25 or best match number 25
and as you might imagine it took many
attempts until bm25 was developed
for our purposes unlike tf-idf
therm-frequency in the m25
saturates towards the constant value for
each term
and also it penalizes longer documents
when counting frequencies
since a longer document will naturally
contain more occurrences of its terms
these are the main differences and it
really helps bm-25 in practice be a much
stronger term waiting model
now that we've decided the behavior of
these
you know waiting functions or at least a
couple of them how would we actually
implement this as an actual system that
we could use for search
um so let's think about this whereas the
row collection the actual text supports
fast access from documents to terms
so basically tokenization gives us the
terms of each document
the term document matrix that we've
studied so far allows fast access from a
term to the documents so it's a bit of a
reverse process
unfortunately the term document matrix
is way too sparse and contains too many
zeros to be useful since the average
term does not occur in the vast majority
of documents if you think about it
so the inverted index that's where it
comes in this is a data structure that
solves this problem it is essentially
just a sparse representation of our
matrix here
which maps each unique term in the
collection so each unique term in our
vocabulary
to what we call a posting list
the posting list
of a term t
simply enumerates all of the actual
occurrences of the term t in the
documents
recording both the id of each document
in which the term t appears and also its
frequency in each of these documents
so beyond term weighting models ir of
course contains lots of models for other
things so there are models for expanding
queries and documents
this basically entails adding new terms
to queries or to documents or to both to
help with the vocabulary mismatch
problem that we discussed in the first
screencast of the series
basically when queries and documents use
different terms to express the same
thing
there's also plenty of work on term
dependence and phrase search notice that
so far we've assumed the terms in each
query and in each document are
independent and we function in a bag of
words
fashion
but work on term dependence and phrase
search relaxes these assumptions
that each query is a bag of independent
terms
lastly there's also lots of work on
learning to rank with various features
like how to estimate relevance when
documents have multiple fields like
maybe a title a body some headings a
footer and also anchor text which is a
very strong signal when you have it like
in web search so this is basically the
text
from links in other pages to your page
the text in those links or around those
links tends to be
very useful
as a relevant signal
and of course also things like page rank
with link analysis and lots of other
features for ir like recency and other
stuff
but i think it's worth mentioning that
until recently if you just had a
collection that you want to search and
you didn't want to do a lot of tuning
bm25 was a very strong baseline
um on the best that you could do ad hoc
so without loss of tuning and and
you know without lots of training data
etc and this only changed a year or two
ago with the advent of birth based
ranking which we'll discuss in detail in
the next screencast of the sit of the
series okay
so we just built an ir system
how do we evaluate our work what is
success like
well a search system as you can imagine
must be both efficient and effective
you know if we had infinite time and
infinite resources we would just hire
experts to look through all the
documents one by one to conduct the
search but clearly we don't have that
sort of ability
so efficiency in ir is paramount after
all we want our retrieval models to work
with sub-second latencies for
collections that may have hundreds of
millions of documents if not even larger
than that
the most common measure of efficiency in
ir is latency which is simply the time
it takes to run one query through the
system say on average or perhaps at the
tail like the 95th percentile for
example
but you can also measure throughput
in queries per second
space how much you know maybe the
inverted index takes on disk versus you
know say a term document matrix um
how well do you scale to different
collection sizes in terms of the number
of documents or the size of the
documents um
and how do you perform under different
query loads many queries few queries
short queries long queries um and lastly
of course what sort of hardware do you
require is it just one cpu core many
cores a bunch of gpus um but latency
tends to be kind of once you've
determined the other ones
it's the go-to metric in most cases
more central to our discussion today and
we'll focus on this um for the rest of
the screencast is ir effectiveness or
the quality basically of an ir system
and here we ask do our top k rankings
for equity satisfy the user's
information need
answering this question tends to be
harder than evaluation for typical
machine learning tasks like
classification or regression
because we're not really just taking you
know an item and assigning it a class
we're trying to rank
all of the items in our corpus with
respect to equity
in practice if you have lots of users
you could run online experiments
where you basically give different
versions of your system to different
users
and compare
some metrics of satisfaction or
conversion basically in terms of you
know purchases or otherwise but for
research purposes we're typically
interested in reusable test collections
test connections that allow us to
evaluate ir models offline and then
compare them against each other
building a test collection entails three
things
first we need to decide on a document
collection our corpus
a set of test queries and we need to
find or get or produce relevant
assessments for each query
if resources permit a collection could
also include a train dev split of
queries
but given the high annotation cost it's
actually not uncommon in ir to find
or create only a test set
the key component of a test collection
is the relevant assessments these are
basically human annotated labels for
each query
that enumerate for us either whether
specific documents are relevant or not
to that query
these query document assessments can
either be binary or they could take on a
more fine-grained graded nature
an example of that is grading a query
document pair as minus one zero one or
two with meanings of hey this is a junk
document minus one you should not
retrieve it for any query or this
document is irrelevant um but but it
might be useful for other queries or
this document is quite relevant for this
query but it's not a perfect match or
you know here is a really really good
match um for our query which would be a
score of two or three depending on um
the the grades that you're using
for for the assessments
as you might imagine because we work
with you know potentially many millions
of documents it's usually infeasible to
judge every single document for every
single query
so instead we're often forced to make
the assumption that unjudged documents
are not relevant
or at least to ignore them
in some metrics of ir though for most
purposes they are treated as not
relevant
some test collections take this further
and only label one or two key documents
per query as relevant and assume
everything else is not relevant
so this tends to be useful when you work
with particular data sets and you want
to keep it in mind as you do evaluation
so many of the test collections out
there in ir are annotated by trek or the
text retrieval conference which includes
annual tracks for competing
and comparing ir systems
for instance the 2021 trek conference
has tracks for search in the context of
conversational assistance health
misinformation fair ranking and has a
very popular deep rank deep learning
track as well which we'll discuss in
more detail
each trek campaign emphasizes careful
evaluation with a very small set of
queries so just 50 queries is a very
typical size actually
but track extensively judges many many
documents possibly hundreds of documents
or even more
for each query here
um so you can imagine an alternative
which we look at next where you have
lots of queries but you only judge a
very small number of um of key documents
um for those queries with the intention
that the performance that you get will
average out over a large enough set of
queries
and this is exactly what happens in ms
marco ranking tasks
which is a collection of
really popular
ir benchmarks
by microsoft ms marco contains more than
half a million bing search queries and
this is the largest public ir benchmark
each query here is
assessed with one or two relevant
documents and we assume everything else
is not relevant
and
you know having this sparse annotation
is often not a problem at all for
training
because we have so many training
instances
and so ms marco
provides a tremendous resource for us
when it comes to building and training
our models especially in the neural
domain
it also turns out that sparse labels are
not too bad for evaluation either
especially because of the size
of the test queries we can use many
thousands of test queries and average
our results across all of them to get a
pretty reliable signal about how
different systems compare
there are multiple test collections out
there on top of ms marco um so there's
the original passage ranking task
a newer document ranking task where the
documents are much longer
but there's fewer of them um and then
there is also attract the track deep
learning track which we've mentioned
before which is happening every year
since 2019
um and which uses the ms marco data
especially for for training mostly um
but has far fewer queries for testing
with lots more
labels for evaluation a lot more
extensive assessments and judgments for
evaluation so these are much denser
labels
there are also plenty of other rather
domain specific ir benchmarks
many of which are collected in this
table
by nanda by nand and ital
in a very recent preprint
as you can see these benchmarks vary
greatly in terms of the training size um
if there is any training at all
um the test set size the average query
length the average document length and
many other factors
beer or benchmarking for ir is a recent
effort
by nand and ital here
to use all of these different data sets
for zero shot or out of domain testing
of ir models specifically in the air we
take already trained ir models that do
not have access to any validation or
training data
on these downstream ir tasks and test
them out out of the box to observe their
out of domain retrieval quality so that
is without training
on these
new domains
okay
so we now have a test collection with
queries documents and assessments
how do we compare ir systems on this
collection
first we will ask each ir system to
produce its top k ranking say its top 10
results and we'll use an ir metric to
compare all of these systems at that
cutoff k
the choice of ir metric and the car of k
will depend entirely on the task so i
will briefly motivate each metric as we
go through them
all of the metrics we will go through
are simply averaged across all queries
and so to keep things simple i will show
the computation of the metric for just
one query in each case but you want to
keep in mind that this is averaged
across queries
let us start with two of the simplest ir
metrics
which are success and mrr
for a given query let rank
be the position of the first relevant
document that we can see in the top k
list of results
success at k
will just be 1 if there is a relevant
result in the top k list and 0 otherwise
this is a very simple metric as you can
see it can be useful in cases where we
assume that the user just needs one
relevant result anywhere in the top k
and in particular it can be useful if if
our retrieval is fed to a downstream
model that looks at the top k results
and then does something with them so it
can read all of them and it will read
all of them anyway
so we're just interested in binary
relevance here
mean reciprocal rank or mrr
also assumes that the user only need
needs one relevant query in the top k
but it assumes that the user does care
about the position of that relevant
document in the ranking
so a relevant document at the second
position for example is only given half
of the weight of a relevant document in
the top position
you're probably already familiar with
precision and recall but let's define
them here in the context of top k ranked
retrieval
for a given query let red of k
be the top k retrieved documents that
set of top kr3 documents and let rel be
the set of all documents that we judged
as relevance as part of our
as part of our assessments
in this case precision at k is just a
fraction of the retrieved items that are
actually relevant
and recall that k is the fraction of all
relevant items that are actually
retrieved
a pretty popular metric is also map or
mean average precision or just average
precision for one query
which essentially brings together
notions from both precision and recall
to compute average precision for one
query we will add up the precision at i
for every position i from 1 through k
where the if document is relevant
we will divide this whole quantity by
the total number of documents that were
judged as relevant for this query
all of the metrics that we've considered
so far only interact with binary
relevance that is they just care whether
each document that is retrieved is
considered relevant or not relevant
dcg or discounted cumulative gain works
with graded relevance so for instance 0
1 2 and 3.
for each position in the ranking from 1
through k we will divide the graded
relevance of the retrieved document
at that position
by the logarithm of the position which
essentially discounts the value of a
relevant document if it appears late in
the ranking
unlike the other metrics the maximum dcg
is often not equal to 1.
so we can also compute normalized dcg or
ndcg by dividing for each query by the
ideal pcg
this is obtained um basically if all of
the relevant documents are at the top of
our top k ranking and that and they are
sorted by decreasing relevance
so all of the twos before all of the
ones before all of the you know the
zeros in this case that are not relevant
all right having discussed classical ir
and evaluation in this screencast we
will focus on neural ir and in
particular state-of-the-art ir models
that use what we've learned so far in
nlu in the next screencast